(tirs)
- Depuis l'annonce
du gouvernement fédéral
d'interdire l'importation
des armes de poing,
les ventes ont explosé.
PIERRE PHARAND, copropriétaire
Club de tir de l'Outaouais
- Depuis deux à trois mois,
j'aiaiaiais vendu cette quantité
d'armes en... dans les huit
dernières années.
Ça vous donne une idée!
(tir)
- Les demandes proviennent
essentiellement d'amateurs
de tir sportif.
- Je vous dirais que
j'ai vendu 400 % de ce que
je vends normalement, au moins
quatre fois. J'ai des armes qui
rentrent puis ils sont pas ici
plus que deux ou trois jours.
- Cette interdiction est une
étape en attendant l'adoption
du projet de loi C-21.
FRANCIS LANGLOIS, chercheur,
Chaire Raoul-Dandurand, UQAM
- Le ministre de la Sécurité
publique, M. Mendicino,
s'attaque à la violence
potentielle éventuelle
qui pourrait être menée
avec des armes qui sont détenues
légalement par des citoyens,
citoyennes canadiennes.
Donc, par exemple, on parle
de suicides, d'accidents,
de tueries de masse,
mais ça ne s'attaque pas
vraiment sur la violence
qu'on voit dans leeseses
des grandes villes canadiennes.
- Car pour lutter
contre la violence armée,
il faut aussi lutter contre
le trafic mememes illégales.
- Le gouvernement fédéral
a injecté des sommes
à la frontière; j'espère
qu'il va en mettre plus.
Mais c c c'est à court terme.
À long terme, il faut donc
changer les conditions de vie
des communautés qui sont
affectées par cette violence-làs
de la tuerie de Polytechnique,
l'approche doit aussi
être globale.
NATHALIE PROVOST, survivante,
porte-parole de PolySeSouvient
- Il faut travailler au plan
de la sécurité pququque,
à la prévention du crime,
à réduire l'influence
des gangs armés. Il faut
travailler en santé mentale,
mais il  t t travailler aussi
en contrôle des armes à feu.
Et c'est l'ensemble des mesures
qui va assurer la sécurité
publique des Canadiens
- Si les ventes ont augmenté
durant les derniers mois,
la crainte de voir émerger
un marché noir i i invoquée
par cet armurier.
- Maintenant, quand
les personnes vont vouloir avoir
des armeususus tard, ils vont se
retourner vers le marché noir
et en allant sur le marché noir,
il n'y a plus personne qui
avavavoir qui a des armes,
il est-tu légal d'avoir
des armes, puis quelles
sont les armes qui se promènent
au Canada. On ne sera plus là
- À l'heure où les fusillades
se multiplient, le contrôle
des armes à feu avance
par étapes. Une mesure
à la fois, en attendant
de franchir ou pas le vote
à la Chambre des communes.
Ici Yasmine Khayat,
Radio-Canada, Montréa